my gosh big cat i'll tell you what i've
seen some ugly moments over the years
while watching nfl football but i can't
think of an uglier visual than a player
removing another player's helmet and
then swinging it at him and hitting him
in the head with it it happened with 14
seconds left last night in cleveland's
win over the pittsburgh steelers the
browns won 21-7 total garbage time
everybody's just trying to get out of
there now look mason rudolph wrestling
with miles garrett on the ground and it
looked at one point like rudolph was
trying to take off garrett's helmet well
he was unsuccessful garrett was
successful off went rudolph's helmet and
then garrett hit rudolph
with his own helmet something we've
never seen before i think the closest we
came was lyle alzado back in the 80s
ripping off a guy's helmet and throwing
it at him not hitting him with it in the
head just throwing it at him this is
helmet off and whacked on top of the
head somehow mason rudolph was not
rendered unconscious like he was a few
weeks ago when he took a helmet to
helmet hit from earl thomas of the
ravens just a horrible visual for the
nfl at a time when the nfl is very
serious about player health and safety
this is not going to be a good week for
miles garrett or the cleveland browns
because i think the aftermath of this
thing big cat is going to entail a
suspension that at least carries through
the rest of the season the real question
for me is whether it goes beyond the
2019 season
the the part about uh we're lucky that
mason rudolph didn't get hurt more
you're absolutely right and if you look
at it it's clear that the helmet kind of
hit him where the soft padding is and
that probably saved us something a lot
worse
the crazy thing to me mike is that miles
garrett you know up until he rips his uh
mason rudolph's helmet off
if he just throws it right there it's
nothing it's a great rivalry game it's
one of those classic games where you say
afc north football can't wait to watch
these two teams play in two weeks like
if he had just stopped at that moment
where he rips mesa rudolph's helmet off
we've seen that happen before we've seen
guys go at each other in that kind of
manner it's everything that happened
after that we're just all hell broke
loose and i i agree with you that we
haven't seen anything like this i will
kind of push back on you that this is
the worst thing we've seen on a football
field because i think we've seen guys
get paralyzed we saw like i said a guy
bleeding out of his ear two hours
earlier so there has been that's the
only funny thing that i see at least on
twitter the instant reaction where
everyone says this is i cannot believe
i'm watching this well
let's just remember this is a football
game and guys are going at each other a
million miles an hour and of course this
is outside of the football game and
that's my point that's where it becomes
an issue but right this is also still a
very violent football game and there is
something weird about our brains where
we watch guys go launching each other at
each other a million miles an hour and
again i said i said it and it's the
truth there was a guy bleeding out of
his ear two hours earlier but then when
someone gets hit with a helmet outside
of the game now it's the most disgusting
you know act of violence we've ever seen
so i think that's a little weird thing
that we play with our brain and everyone
gets very upset and i understand it's
obviously not inside the game but it's a
weird dynamic that i see on twitter i
get that but you're also watching
can i can i can i at some point are you
going to filibuster all the way to the
break the hard break at the end of the
half hour what are you going to do here
here's the point it is completely and
totally beyond the boundary of what you
expect and accept when you walk onto a
football field you do not abandon the
rules of society when you play football
when you play hockey when you play
basketball when you play baseball marty
mcsorley in 2000 ultimately was charged
with assault and was sentenced to 18
months of probation for whacking donald
brashear in the head with a stick there
are limits even in hockey where they get
it on and they throw the gloves down and
they fight but it's one thing to fight
with your knuckles it's another thing to
use your stick as a weapon there are
lines you can't cross that's my point
yes we have seen guys horribly injured
and paralyzed those are all things that
have happened within the confines of
playing football not within the confines
of someone saying i'm going to take a
street fight and i'm going to have it
play out on a football field well after
the play that's my point and this is
right up there with what albert
haynesworth did to andre garrod now
hainsworth kind of pulled the helmet off
a garage and then stomped on his
forehead and and look it it was bloody
it was nasty and that was all before the
nfl had its epiphany about player health
and safety and the suspension then was
five games this is the first time we've
seen this kind of deliberate misconduct
after the nfl decided to get serious
about health and safety and that's where
the real test is going to be what is the
nfl going to do because now the nfl
supposedly cares about players overall
health and safety well and there's
another important distinction here mike
that makes it different than the albert
haynesworth and it makes it different
than the sioux it's
a
prime time game where everyone watched
the replay over and over and over and
over again if this was a one o'clock on
a sunday i genuinely think yes people
would be very uh they'd have similar
reactions but i don't think it would
dominate the news cycle like it is right
now because it's a standalone game and
two it happened to a quarterback and i
don't you can tell me that i'm way off
on this but i think that if miles
garrett does to does what he did to
masonry off to an offensive lineman the
reaction that people have to it is
completely different i think there is a
idea of of protecting quarterbacks and
we saw listen last big moment we saw
from mason rudolph because this he
hasn't been good let's just say that on
the field the last big moment we saw was
when he had a very violent concussion
against baltimore so people have that
visual in their head as well where they
were they're saying mason rudolph is
coming off a severe severe concussion
where he was you know had to come off
the field and they had to take his face
mask off and now not a month later he's
getting hit on the on the head with a
helmet so i think those two things might
add to
the reaction and what the punishment
will be not only the the epiphany that
the nfl had about player safety in 2009
but the fact that it was a prime time
game and the fact that it was a
quarterback who got hit not a lyman
onlineman thing and you're right if
there had been an injury inflicted on
mason rudolph if he just collapses in a
heap like he did when he was hit by earl
thomas within the confines of the game
then i think you do have to raise the
question of whether or not miles garrett
gets charged and prosecuted for assault
i really do because the laws do not
suspend when you walk onto the football
field but apart from that it's a
horrible visual for the nfl that we're
going to see over and over again all
weekend long we're going to be talking
about it on sunday i already expect that
there'll be a segment on football night
in america where we address the timing
of the miles garrett suspension because
usually they wait until the weekend is
completely over
the smart move would be to go ahead and
suspend him today so we're not spending
all of sunday replaying that moment
talking about what may happen to miles
garrett just get it done now there's no
reason to wait until monday and the nfl
would be wise to move forward and
implement the punishment today before
the weekend rolls around but the fact
look we're already conditioned to
believe that quarterbacks should be
protected because they are protected
when they're in the pocket passing and
you mentioned the mason rudolph
circumstance what if this had been a tom
brady a patrick mahomes and aaron
rodgers a star quarterback it would have
been even worse it's just mason rudolph
and no disrespect to mason rudolph but i
spent a lot of last night wondering
whether or not he should be benched for
devlin hodges or whether or not they
should go to the colin kaepernick
workout and seriously consider signing
him because he may be better than the
guys they currently have available and
even though it's only mason rudolph it's
still an egregious act yeah yeah you're
absolutely right the one thing i want to
push back on that i've seen a lot on
twitter and you just mentioned it the uh
idea that like if this had happened in a
workplace a regular workplace the person
would be in jail
i think that that's a little bit much
because guess what the nfl football
field that's not a regular workplace and
again that's not excusing whatsoever
what miles garrett did i think the
people who are out there right now
saying well mason rudolph started it and
tried to grab his helmet that's crazy
again if miles garrett rips mason
rudolph's helmet off and tosses it into
the stands it's a completely different
visual everything that he did from the
moment he ripped his helmet off
afterwards is where it's a big big
problem i like we've seen guys rip each
other's helmets off before a million
times that seems normal but this is
again not a regular workplace it's not
like you know walking into deloitte and
someone bashing you over the head with a
helmet it's a football field it's the
national football league these guys are
playing a very violent physical sport
and adrenaline is coursing through their
veins and it's hard to turn off that
switch uh so i i don't know if we like
if everyone i completely disagree with
you i completely disagree with you okay
because there are limits to the accepted
violence in any of these sports and if
you're not capable of understanding
where that line is then you shouldn't be
playing in the nfl period that's why the
point i've been i've been making the
commissioner always says that playing in
the nfl is a privilege not a right is do
they really mean that because there are
other guys out there because i i think
what you're doing in a roundabout way
and i don't think you're doing it on
purpose you're demeaning all football
players by suggesting that they're these
neanderthals that can't turn it off no
you have to be able to turn it off you
have to be able to turn it off and what
he did last night was so far after the
play ended that that you can't just say
well it's football so you have to accept
it maybe you're gonna get whacked in the
head with your own helmet what i'm
saying is there's nuance to all of this
that people are just painting it
completely black and white and saying if
you if this happened in your office you
would be in jail right now
it's this is not normal like it's not
the normal life these are these are
athletes that are 0.001
of the population they are
insane so they should be disputes by
whacking each other in the heavens
i'm just saying i think that people yes
you are no they no that's exactly what
you're saying it is exactly what you're
saying i'm not i'm not trivializing it
all because i think again miles garrett
should be suspended he should be
suspended for the rest of the year and i
think it's actually it could even maybe
leak into next year because what he did
you're absolutely right you can't do
under any circumstance whatsoever i just
think it's funny we do this with we i
mean mike we do this with everything
when it comes to support hang on a
second
well i came back in six months listen
listen
the the
here's the reality there are a lot of
stressful jobs out there we are blessed
and fortunate that our jobs do not
entail the kind of stress that other
jobs have and you mentioned deloitte
right in an accounting firm there are
moments of high stress when you practice
law there are moments of high stress and
there have been times when i was
practicing law that i wanted to punch
someone in the face right you have to
restrain that you have to control that
in a civilized society and the rules of
a civilized society are not abandoned
simply because you're playing football
there is a point where you have to
comply with what the other humans expect
and the other humans expect not to be
punched in the face not to be hit in the
head with our own helmet not to be
jacked upside the head with a stapler
these are things that we should all
expect no matter what your profession is
mike here's the difference okay and
here's where i maybe i didn't do a good
job of explaining it when you are
playing in the nfl you are playing
a sport in a game that is violent by
nature you are always on that edge you
were always on that line we talk about
it all the time about guys playing on
that line where they're playing within
the confines of the game but they are
physically imposing on the other team
i think and again this is no in no
defense of miles garrett i think there
is a difference between what happens on
a football field when you're always
playing on that violent edge and what
happens sitting there in your office and
being like well if this happened in my
office it would be totally different
yeah of course it would be totally the
same it would be totally different it's
just a different set of circumstances
and i just it's it's i think what i'm
doing is actually humanizing the players
more than anything in saying that they
play a sport that takes such a toll and
has them playing on such a line
that something like this can happen and
again not excusing it but it can happen
this is what
they're always on that line where it's
like we want you to play at your
physical best we want you to play your
physical most violent imposing
you know going at the other team
that switch is a lot closer your
finger's a lot closer to that switch
than if you're sitting behind a cube
here's here's one thing i want us all to
remember when february rolls around and
we hear the stories about the stupid
questions that get asked of the players
at the scouting combine and the
different circumstances to try to put
them in this is exactly what the teams
are trying to screen they're trying to
figure out which guys are going to blow
a gasket in the heat of the moment and
which ones aren't and either the browns
knew or the brown should have known that
miles garrett is potentially going to
blow a gasket like that now maybe this
is the first time in his life something
like this has ever happened but this is
why they ask those stupid questions that
we like to complain about they want to
find out which guys are going to be able
to keep their cool in those moments of
high stress and which ones aren't
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports